[Music]
to president of the European commission
dear ministers distinguished guests
it's my honor to welcome you all here in
Tallinn
when times are hard we must stand United
United in solidarity with the people of
Ukraine
Russia must may be testing us
and trying to divide us but we can show
that it's in mission impossible for him
we are not here today to talk about the
past or even the present we are here
today to talk about the future
we have had a reality check we have had
to face Russia's war against Ukraine and
the covid-19 lockdowns and increasing
rivalry and with authoritarian countries
physical and cyber attacks against vital
infrastructure
we see what happens when we connect
ourselves to Partners who weaponize our
trust
we became over-reliant of our for our
essential needs on countries who do not
share the same values but the area of
such interdependencies has come to close
now we have entered a new area of
globalization that prioritizes security
over economic efficiency we need to
rethink existing political and economic
alliances
we have NATO for Collective military
defense
but where can we turn to in case of
Economic Security
and what should a trusted economic
architecture fits for the 21st century
looked like
instead of waiting solutions to come to
us we should offer them that is how we
operate in Estonia
and that is why we are here today to
harness our economic power and our moral
leadership
articulate a vision for a future that is
free open secure and prosperous
a future where Europe
and its Partners lead in solidarity and
with competitive advantage
a future defined by trusted connections
and trusted Partnerships
the foundations of this future are
trusted connectivity and the global
gateway
Estonia owning to its history and
geography has long been very of
unreliable Partners it was our conscious
decision many years ago to decouple
ourselves from Russian energy this came
at the considerable cost
today Estonia is one of the few European
countries least reliant on Russian gas
we knew that the prevention is better
and far far less costly than the Cure
this is why at the same venue just one
year ago Estonia introduced trusted
connectivity a conceptual framework
for organizing political and economic
relations among trusted partners namely
trusted Partners across the world who
are committed to upholding the
rules-based order and to protecting
human rights and individual freedom
the proposition of trusted connectivity
is straightforward to connect the
like-minded countries through trusted
Partnerships based on shared interests
and values and the highest standards
thus reinforcing trust in global
political and economic relations across
the Free World
the European Union's global gateway is
the embodiment of trusted connectivity
in practice it is team Europe's positive
value-based offer of cooperation to
develop countries and emerging economies
alike
it is an offer to deliver economic and
energy security and to bridge digital
divides
governments financial institutions and
the private sector all working together
to boost competitiveness deliver
benefits to Partners and Empower local
communities
the global gateway also advances
Europe's strategic autonomy being
reflection of our trailblazing
legislation on critical raw materials
batteries and semiconductors and it is
already delivering on the ground in
Africa in the western Balkans Latin
America the Caucasus Central Asia with
many more projects soon to follow
ladies and gentlemen
the three worlds united front against
authoritarianism is being tested and
it's growing stronger in it
we have seen the recent introduction of
many trusted connectivity initiatives
not only the global gateway but also
g7's partnership for infrastructure and
investment
the three C's initiative the United
Kingdom's clean green initiative the
indo-pacific economic framework for
Prosperity Africa's agenda 2063.
these will allow us to build
Partnerships not dependencies
it is trusted connectivity that ties
these many initiatives together as a
concept it clearly expresses the values
we hold there
as a framework it enables practical
interoperability across these
initiatives by creating a mutual
understanding
and it offers the necessary context for
engaging with authoritarian regimes
trusted connectivity informs our
tea cup playing phone from an unreliable
Partners replacing these with trusted
Alternatives whether we talk about the
global value chains submarine cables
Finance or new technologies
and this is vital
because it is connectivity digital and
physical infrastructure that is in the
heart at the heart of Our Moment In
crisis
connectivity links up National Economic
energy and cyber security it links up
the digital and green Transformations it
links up trade and Supply chains
connectivity is the smartphone in your
pocket the lights in this room
and the tax return you submit online it
is the source code of our e-government
and it's the software in 5G networks and
thus our digital existence also reflects
our values and standards
there is immense Global demand for
infrastructure we cannot let autocracies
be the ones who respond to this demand
uncontested
we have seen where this leads the
Synergy of failures
investments from autocracies corrode
good governance and pollute the
environment
they drive the recipient country into
death trap
this is the high cost of Independence
and the most harm is suffered by the
most vulnerable
they're participants We Stand strongest
When We Stand United the European Union
responded to Our Moment In crisis with
solidarity and resolve
all together as team Europe NATO and The
Wider transatlantic Community are
stronger than before
are offered to the world of positive
values-based trusted Partnerships is a
message that Rings louder than it rang
before
and I strongly believe we are more ready
to rise to the occasion than before
as we respond to our shared challenges
today we are tracing a path to brighter
tomorrow on this path we need to ask
ourselves are we willing to pay the
premium of trust or are we not
I think the answer is very clear trust
may come at the price but it is price
worth paying
we cannot let the sacrifices Ukraine has
made be in vain
we have to learn the lessons of
over-reliance and interdependence
we have to ensure that freedom
Prosperity security and democracy
prevail
so let us stand together let us show we
are in it for the long haul let us Build
The Better Tomorrow
together
alongside with our friends from the
United States the G7 in the Pacific
Africa Latin America and Beyond
this is the promise of trusted
connectivity and the global gateway
I'm glad to welcome Ursula Van Der Lyon
here with us today to tell us about the
positive vision of a global gateway
I commend her personal leadership on
this issue and and to this initiative
I welcome all of you who are here in
person and also those who are watching
us online
we will not resolve our problems in
these two short days but laying the
groundwork begins Here and Now
this is what the talent digital Summit
is all about a platform for the global
gateway and other trusted connectivity
initiatives to convene and coordinate
to mobilize our Collective power across
all Collective efforts
and I'm positive telling will continue
to offer a crucial meeting place for
European and other global leaders to
make trust not dependency
key part of the future we are building
thank you
[Applause]
thank you prime minister for always
being so honest and straightforward I
think we all need this rally to check
but for now you also mentioned the
global gateway and we will have a short
video introducing us uh to realize what
global gateway means to each and every
one of us
I learned so many different things that
I never could have discovered by myself
[Music]
Missouri
Grande
[Applause]
with that
I'm more than glad and very honored to
invite on the stage Madame wonderlighten
the president of the European commission
please
[Applause]
[Music]
prime minister
my dear Kaya dear prime minister kalas
prime minister Negril
excellencies ladies and gentlemen I'm
very glad to join you here today in
Tallinn at the digital Summit
here in Estonia the word of this
conference connectivity has a very
special sound
I mean you have next door a country that
is trying to use our interconnections as
a weapon against us
because Russia is not only Waging War on
Ukraine
Russia's Waging War on our energy
on our democracies
on our values
and Estonia like many of the Baltic
states
has been warning Europe since years
about the dangers of our dependency on
Russian fossil fuels
and you were right
you are right and Europe should have
followed your example earlier
ever since you broke free from Soviet
you rule you've been working very hard
to get rid of Russian fossil fuels and
to disconnect from the Russian grid
you have invested heavily into renewable
energy
into LNG terminals into new
interconnectors with the rest of Europe
and on top you have become global
leaders in cyber security and in the
digital field
today
you're standing strong before a hostile
neighbor
so from a small country like yours comes
a great example for our entire European
Union
this must be a lesson for all of us
especially as the war in Ukraine has now
entered a new phase
faced with the brave Ukrainian
resistance
the Kremlin has once again escalated
its aggression to a new level
Putin has launched Russia's first
mobilization since World War II
he has used Sham referenda in an illegal
attempt
to change International borders by force
all of this while redoubling his efforts
to destabilize Global energy security
but this will only strengthen our
resolve to support Ukraine as long as it
takes
but this new phase of the war also
called for renewed action
on our energy Independence
on our infrastructure
and on building new Partnerships with
the rest of the world
in short it calls for a new investment
into trusted connectivity
today I would like to focus on three
issues in particular the first one is we
need to protect our critical
infrastructure
the second topic is about we need to
keep replacing unsustainable dependency
with more balanced cooperation
and the third topic is about that we
need to continue to build trust in
global connectivity
let me begin with a physical
infrastructure that underpins
connectivity
the acts of sabotage against the north
stream pipelines have shown how
vulnerable our critical infrastructure
is
pipelines and underwater cable connect
European citizens and the companies
across the world
they are the lifelines of financial
markets and global trade
and they are essential for services such
as Modern Health Care for example or
energy
submarine Fiber Optic Cables carry 99
of global internet traffic
and now
for the very first time in modern
history
this infrastructure has become a Target
so the task ahead of us is clear
we need to better protect our lifelines
of the world economy
and we have carved out five different
strands of actions
and let me briefly reflect on them with
you here
first of all of course we must be better
prepared
now the good news is that we have just
brand new European legislation
which will strengthen the resilience of
critical EU entities so what we have to
do now with this new legislation that
was done under the French presidency
what we have to do now is implement it
put it on the ground that it is really
working and developing a track record
second
we need to stress test our
infrastructure
we need to identify the weak points
and prepare our reaction to sudden
disruption we all know how important
stress tests are to make sure that
everyone knows what to do in a case of
emergency
so we will work with the member states
to do these stress tests in the field of
energy
and other high-risk sectors
such as offshore digital and the
electricity infrastructure for example
the third point is we will increase our
capacity on the European level
to respond through our civil protection
mechanism if needed
with this we can support member states
in case of disruption of critical
infrastructure with very practical
things like fuel supplies generators
shelter capacity all these things have
to be in place
and then we will make best use of our
satellite surveyance capacity to detect
potential threats we have this capacity
we should use it much much more to
really know what's going on in the
different areas of our critical
infrastructure
and last not but but not least we will
strengthen cooperation of course with
NATO on this subject and partners like
for example our American friends
critical infrastructure
is the New Frontier of welfare
and Europe will be prepared
In The Same Spirit
we have to step up our support for our
Ukrainian friends
time and again you have watched it and
been witnessing this in the last month
Russia has been trying to take down
Ukraine's I.T systems
therefore the European Union has
mobilized financial support for
emergency cyber security for Ukraine
we've helped move government servers to
Safe locations
and this direct assistance is Multiplied
multiplied by member states many thanks
also to our host Estonia you've done a
great job on that one
I know you've done a great job on that
one because you understand very well by
bitter experience
that and the struggle between democracy
and autocracy
the digital sphere is not a sideshow but
it is front line
this is the critical infrastructure and
the question how we can better prepare
to protect it the physical
infrastructure
structure let me move on to the second
point
that is that we have to replace
unsustainable dependency which we do
have
with balanced cooperation that we want
with trusted partners
for that that we have to double down on
our positive engagement with the rest of
the world and continue to act in a
spirit of openness of cooperation and of
trust that's the motto of this Summit
just last year just to give you some
examples
we inaugurated the Ella link
Transatlantic cable connecting Europe
with Latin America
revolutionary
and we're now deploying a new fiber
optic cable under the Black Sea
it will diversify internet access across
Central Asia and reduce dependency on
terrestrial cables that go through
Russia
this project is one of the typical
projects of global gateway if we've
heard already a lot about it global
gateway as you know our big investment
project of 300 billion euros for
Investments abroad in trusted
connectivity
and I'm very glad to see the Prime
Minister here of Rwanda
that is present we have for example a
typical global gateway project that is
building up a vaccination manufacturing
capacity
with the experience of the pandemic we
have decided to say listen there needs
to be manufacturing capacity in Africa
of a marine vaccines not only for covet
but potentially later to fight malaria
tuberculosis and other diseases killing
diseases
and here we've done what is typical for
global gateway
come with public money but also come
with our legal framework for example for
pharmaceuticals that has to be in place
attract private Capital have a partner
on the ground that is working with us to
make sure that the project develops this
is one of the typical projects we have
to and we need more infrastructure like
this
in our neighborhood managed through
global gateway and funded through global
gateway
we also need this kind of infrastructure
to connect Ukraine to connect Moldova
Georgia and the Western Balkans more
tightly to our Union
and we can do it we have the experience
we have shown this
let me give you an example that is
typical
it was about two weeks after Russia's
invasion
that we successfully connected the
Europe the European electrical grid with
the Ukrainian electrical grid they
decoupled from Russia
and that was a move I was told before
the war that was planned for 2024.
so two years ahead of us
we were able to manage that and to do
that in two weeks
and these are exactly the projects that
have to be done through global gateway
here we needed to really join forces of
course to invest massively but we did it
within two weeks was what planned for
two years
so now Ukraine is an important you new
import of electricity to the European
Union that creates a revenue stream for
Ukraine and our Union can rely on
electricity from Ukraine to help tackle
the energy crisis
and in case of need we can provide them
with electricity
this is just one example in the broad
attempt to get rid of Russian energy
supplies
we have been working hard the last seven
months
since Russia invaded Ukraine and we've
been working with success to get rid of
our dependency on Russian fossil fuels
we have completely cut off the supply of
Russian coal
and if I can give you two figures what
Russian gas is concerned
last year
of all the gas imported to the European
Union 40 percent was Russian gas
now in seven months we've been able to
decrease that dependency down to 7.5
percent only of Russian gas in the
overall supply of European gas from
abroad again crucial was here
having the right infrastructure in place
and the good news is that Europe is
making more progress by the day the
speed is accelerating because the
pressure is high and that's good just
some days ago we inaugurated a new gas
interconnector between Bulgaria and
Greece
it brings gas from Azerbaijan and from
Mediterranean LNG terminals not only via
Greece to Bulgaria but also to Romania
Serbia and North Macedonia
so these examples these interconnections
are game changers in Europe's energy
Supply and energy security
this means access to trusted and
reliable sources of energy everywhere in
our Union
and it means freedom from Russian
dependency and freedom from Russian
blackmail
you were so right
when you were reminding us
of the real price tag that is attached
to dependency on Russia you've been
describing it in your introductory
remarks
we need to keep this firmly in mind as
we transition to renewable sources of
energy
because yes it comes with an investment
but it's worth it because if you look at
the dependency and the price tag that is
coming with the dependency
is this much much more needed to get rid
of this dependency invest in Renewables
and find your Independence every
kilowatt hour
that we receive electricity or energy
from solar or wind is not only good for
our climate it's also good for our
climate and it's necessary but it's good
for our independence and our security of
supply
we have to be if we invest more and more
into Renewables in the future
also from the very start on Vigilant and
we have to be strategic
because Renewables
we want to produce them
often depend on scars raw materials and
that's another topic I want to raise
here
you all know the magnets for wind
turbines the cell for solar panels they
all need Rare Minerals or rare raw
materials
and you know the examples
by 2030
Europe's Demand on those rare earth
metals will increase five-fold five
times what we use today and today it's
already a scarce resource
so the first and foremost good news
behind this five-fold is
that it shows that our European green
deal is moving fast that's good news
the not so good news is
that one country dominates the market
and that is China
so we have to avoid falling into the
same dependency from China
as we were with oil and gas from Russia
and we have to start now
and that is why we're working on a
European critical raw materials Act
it will help to diversify our supply
chains towards trusted partner the motto
of this Summit trusted connectivity
and this will be another crucial domain
for global gateway
global gateway will mobilize the public
and private investment that is needed on
the ground
investments in project abroads that
connect us
but we also have to do our own homework
and let me switch to topics we sometimes
do not look at enough
let me take the topic of semiconductors
for example
which is a good example of our
overarching theme of new forms of
cooperation
as you'll know
semiconductors are on every digital
device from Cars to phones to medical
equipment without chips no modern
economy this is clear
Let me Give an example how crucial these
semiconductors are in the daily life we
have sanctions
the export of semiconductors to Russia
we've banned all export of
semiconductors
and the the impact of these sanctions is
now very really very real tangible on
the ground in Russia
the Russian military for example
cannibalizes by now
refrigerators and washing machines to
take out the semiconductors trying to
get the semiconductors for their
military hardware
so semiconductors are crucial but not
only for others they are also crucial
for us
and therefore our aim is
to increase our global market share
by 20 to 20 percent by 2030.
and we have all we need to achieve this
what are we doing we have world-class
research and testing facilities this is
attractive for investors but not enough
to create the necessary ecosystem thus
with our European chips act we've
mobilized billions of investment for
development for mass production of Next
Generation ships
we've just approved for example the
first state aid decision
given the go-ahead to a 730 million euro
investment by a Franco Italian company
to build a new facility in Sicily
it will produce for the very first time
in Europe large-scale silicon carbide
wafers
the base of all semiconductors
and in the coming months a trusted
American company is set to break ground
with its new Chips planned in Germany a
17 billion Euro investment
that is what trusted connectivity looks
like in reality
and that brings me to my third and final
point
it is about trusted connectivity
who defines the rules of the game
high tech is great
but what is the purpose you use it for
who is setting the standards
who is setting the standards that will
govern and protect our societies
is it the market
is it the government like in China
or is it the human-centric approach
that is our European approach
think from the individual and his or her
rights
take the gdpr
as you know born in Europe might not be
perfect but for the very first time
the rules of the game have been defined
and now they are setting data
they are setting data protection and
they are setting standards
from here not only in Europe but also in
Silicon Valley for example they are The
Benchmark for data protection in Silicon
Valley
or take our digital markets and Digital
Services Act
here again Europe is on the Vanguard
bringing the rules of the analog world
into the digital world for the very
first time
there are clear rules on how to deal
with topics like hate speech
disinformation terrorist content online
we're doing the same for product cyber
security with the regulation proposed
next month
Now setting standards for Europe is good
but it is our engagement with our
trusted partners
that makes European standards finally
Global standards
this is one of the reasons for example
why our work with the United States and
recently also with India through our
trade and Technology Council is so
important
set the standards with your friends
or in addition we have teamed up with
the G7 partnership for Global
infrastructure you were describing it
Kaya
with our combined package of 600 billion
dollars we're leveraging not just our
investments that's important but also
our standard setting power
thus
step by step
we are re-anchoring the values and rules
based order
on firmer ground in a modern economy
working with friends working with
Partners through trusted connectivity
the Roman Statesman sitzel famously said
the shifts of Fortune test the
reliability of friends
I'm glad to be among friends
for we cannot always control what
history has in store for us
but we can shape our fortunes we can
influence it by Standing Tall for our
values and by standing United with our
trusted partners and our friends thank
you very much
[Applause]